I mentioned Haiti and all the amazing
work that you've done there and it
occurred to me today
you've done this great work in a lot of
places there's flooding catastrophe in
New Orleans you show up there you you
show up or have a reputation of showing
up when there's trouble and people need
help and it was occurring to me today
that might be a problem in your life
because people might start to expect oh
we've had a problem in our city Sean
Penn's gonna come yeah do you know what
I mean but in a way that would be an
unrealistic expectation do you know what
I mean two versions of that have
happened with me one is people see me
somewhere where there is no problem and
ask me if something bad and you're like
no no I just came to j.crew to get a
sweater I do
but then something bad happened and I'm
it wasn't me
yeah no yeah and then the other is yes
there's an expectation I've gone through
numerous airports where someone who
identifies whatever their sense of Mia's
with with let's say not just with Haiti
right but maybe that in their mind it it
means not with the United States of
America right so you know what are you
doing in Houston yeah where we had our
people working at the time right but I I
kind of want to respond with you first
what are you doing and you you can only
be so many places you put you know so
much work into this and you're writing
now and successfully writing do you ever
feel this sense that like oh I got to
get back and do more acting or is this
stuff feeling more vital to you now I
don't enjoy acting on a movie anymore I
mean if it was something you know a
couple of days right something like that
but I uh I don't update yeah you know
movie could you do literally you just a
movie where your role is to just peek in
and go you know it Clare's anyone know
okay and then shut the door no you you
pay that you play the attendant at the
gas station you have two Academy Awards
it doesn't work of literary you want
regular okay all right you know so that
get you to well paid day
[Laughter]
[Applause]